this is the jocko underground podcast
number four
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
also joining us good deal dave
good evening dave
all right let's get into the topic of
the day so
i had neck issues
my neck my neck i had i had a problem
with my neck
i had well i woke up one day this was
years ago i woke up one day and i
couldn't move my right arm didn't move
so so imagine that you wake up and you
can't move your right arm
had some so
i went to the doctor and
they started figuring out what to do
because i had basically some problems in
my neck that was causing
friction on the nerves that control my
right arm
so i had to
do some physical therapy and eventually
it said they said you know you're gonna
need to get surgery to fix this problem
okay so they gave me
basically two options
well one option was don't get surgery
and
you're
the longer it's in this condition the
worst chance it has of
recovering so that's not good
but you can do it if you don't want to
take any chances
of getting surgery
so they gave me two options so one was
called a foraminotomy which they go in
through the back of your neck and they
basically chip away at some bone and
they give the they give some breathing
room for your nerves
the other one they gave you is the other
option they gave is get a fusion where
they go in the front of your neck
and they
basically carve a bunch of bone out and
then they fuse your neck together so
that it can't move
that one is considered to be the
has it has a superior result
most of the time
it's also the last it's also the last
resort it's also you can't escalate from
there
the other one if you let's say you got
the frame anatomy the one going through
the back and it didn't go well oh it
didn't have the impact that you wanted
it to have well then you could go well
it didn't really work the way i wanted
to now i want to get the other one so
you at least had one more option
so as i considered this actually there
was a there's
you talk through the possible
problems that you could have one of the
problems and this was back in the day so
one of the problems that you can have
when you get a fusion going through the
anterior of your neck the front of your
neck when they're going in there they're
close to your vocal cords and they can
cut your vocal cords and you can't talk
anymore
which
back then i was
it's kind of scary to think now since
the only thing i do for a living is talk
that would not have been cool
and i was thinking at the time well i
i'm in a leadership position i need to
be able to talk to people that that
could be a problem
also there's you can die you know you
can they can just screw up and you can
just paralyze you or they can kill you
so as i'm talking through the doctor who
was
the best
neurosurgeon
in the millet in the navy on the west
coast at the time he was a really
skilled guy
and you know he said so you could die
you this and that and i said yeah you
know
what are the chances i mean one of the
chat i said how many how many sides are
on that dice though and i said like 10
000
and he goes
about 200.
i said to myself that's
okay not exactly what i wanted to hear
uh
but then i told him i said hey listen if
i can if my friends can get hit with
giant pieces of shrapnel flying through
the air and
live i'm sure you were the scalpel on a
sterilized
surgery table you can make this happen
and so i ended up choosing the
frame anatomy to go in through the back
and the main reason why i chose it
is because
you can escalate from there
i had room to maneuver right there was
some place to go
if the fusion front fusion doesn't get
the desired result you're just stuck
with no with with that that's what
you're stuck with so we don't want to
paint ourselves into a corner
as far as i can tell i never want to
paint myself a two corner i never want
to leave myself without any options i
don't want to dig in to a particular
position
i don't want to be in a situation that i
can't get out of
and this is why
it's such a strange thing
because that should be your attitude as
far as i'm concerned i don't know in my
opinion your attitude should be i don't
want to be stuck in a position
you should feel
it should feel wrong
if you're trapping yourself in a
position
which is weird because there's a counter
to that which is you have to be super
determined right you have to be you have
to be super determined
in order to move forward through tough
challenges you've got to be determined
so you got to balance that thing between
being very determined but at the same
time wanted to keep an open mind about
what your options are
you want to have both those things kind
of going on
and i think for me a lot of this boils
down to
thinking strategically versus thinking
tactically
we want to start thinking strategically
instead of thinking tactically which
everyone knows this or you should know
this
we shouldn't be doing things that
benefits us in the short term if they
don't benefit us in the long term as
well
that they're not worth doing
i'm sure are there some little things
hey it's got a little benefit so i'm
going to do it right now it's no there's
no
strategic harm or whatever okay fine but
i'm talking as a habitual way of living
we don't want to do a bunch of things
that are beneficial to us in the short
term
that
hurt us in the long term
i mean just think about your habits as a
human being
between if you decipher or you
discriminate between
this is
good for me long term
this is only good for me short term you
could make so many decisions and they'd
be awesome
if you did things only that were good
for you in the long term
and not just things that are good for
you in the short term but they're bad
for you in the long term the goal of
course is great when you have something
that's good for you in the short term
good for you in the long term super
great that's a no-brainer we don't even
need to talk about that one but how do
we how do we actually start
thinking in a way
that we can think about the bigger
picture
that we can think strategic instead of
thinking tactically
obviously you got to keep your ego in
check because we chase
little tactical victories all the time
we chase little tactical victories all
the time when it comes to leadership
right okay do we chase a donut because a
donut tastes good
sure we do that that's a strategic
strategic loss it's a tactical win it
tastes good
i feel good for
28 minutes after i eat a donut and then
after 32 minutes i feel like a loser
it's actually probably less than that
could even be less than that 25 seconds
28 seconds 28 seconds you feel like bad
yeah after that you figure once it's
down it's almost immediate really just
face it
as far as donuts go yeah
good point
good point
but we do it people do it i mean whole
whole swaths of society
make that decision that's gonna feel
good right now even though they know
they can start to stop watching 28
seconds from now we're gonna feel bad
about it
so
that's that's an extreme example
it's an extreme example
but do you think about something that
there's a little less negative immediate
impact maybe skipping a workout
maybe i'm gonna
maybe i'm gonna
win this argument
now i can't think strategically because
my ego is a problem
because i want to win the argument i
want to prove that i'm right so badly
that
i will
i will detract from our relationship
i'll move things in the wrong direction
but i win this tactical moment
because of my ego
which is crazy to think that we would
actually do that and we do it all the
time people do it all the time
so how do we so how do we start moving
towards strategic thinking
instead of
short-term tactical thinking for
obviously you got to get your ego in
check the second thing you got to do is
you got to get up to altitude
you got to get up to altitude where you
can see more than
just this donut or just this argument
you got to get up to altitude and what
you have to be able to do a little bit
is you have to be able to see into the
future
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to
jockowunderground.com and subscribe and
we're doing this to mitigate our
reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better communications with us
strengthen this legion of troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's jocko underground.com it costs
8.18 a month and if you can't afford to
support us we can still support you just
email assistance
jockonunderground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then
we will see you
mobilized
underground